Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Scientists at Google just released the Translatotron.
This is an AI that is able to translate speech
from one language into speech into another
language, and here comes the first twist,
without using text as an intermediate representation.
You give it the soundwaves, and you get the
translated soundwaves.
And this neural network was trained approximately
on a million voice samples.
So let’s see what learning on this one million
samples gives us.
Listen.
This is the input sentence in Spanish.
And here it is, translated to English, but
using the voice of the same person.
This is incredible.
However, there is another twist, perhaps an
even bigger one, believe it or not.
This technique can not only translate, but
can also perform voice transfer, so it can
say the same thing using someone else’s
voice.
This means that the AI not only has to learn
what to say, but how to say it.
This is immensely difficult.
It’s also not that easy to know what we
need to listen to and when, so let me walk
you through it.
This is a source sentence in Spanish.
This is the same sentence said by someone
else, an actual person, and in English.
And now, the same thing, but synthesized by
the algorithm using both of their voices.
Let’s listen to them side by side some more.
This is so good, let’s have a look at some
more examples.
Wow.
The method performs the learning by trying
to map these Mel spectrograms between multiple
speakers.
You can see example sentences here and their
corresponding spectrograms, which are concise
representations of someone’s voice and intonation.
And of course, it is difficult to mathematically
formalize what makes a good translation and
a good mimicking of someone’s voice, so
in these cases, we let people be the judge
and have them listen to a few speech signals
and asking them to guess which was a real
person, and which was the AI speaking.
If you take a closer look at the paper, you
will see that it smokes the competition.
This is great progress on an immensely difficult
task as we have to perform proper translation
and voice transfer at the same time.
It’s quite a challenge.
Of course, failure cases still exist.
Listen.
Just imagine that you are in a foreign country
and all you need to do is use your phone to
tell stories to people not only in their own
language, but also using your own voice, even
if you don’t speak a word of their language.
Beautiful.
Even this video could perhaps be available
in a variety of languages using my own voice
within the next few years, although I wonder
how these algorithms would pronounce my name.
So far, that proved to be quite a challenge
for humans and AIs alike.
And for now, all hail the mighty Translatotron.
In the meantime, I just got back from this
year’s NATO conference.
It was an incredible honor to get an invitation
to speak at such an event, and of course,
I was happy to attend as a service to the
public.
The goal of the talk was to inform key political
and military decision makers about recent
advancements in AI so they can make better
decisions for us.
And I was SO nervous during the talk.
My goodness.
If you wish to watch it, I put a link to it
in the video description and I may be able
to upload a higher-quality version of this
video here in the future.
Attending the conference introduced delays
in our schedule, my apologies for that, and
normally, we would have to worry whether because
of this, we’ll have enough income to improve
our recording equipment.
However, with your support on Patreon, this
is not at all the case, so I want to send
you a big thank you for all your amazing support.
This was really all possible thanks to you.
If you wish to support us, just go to patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers
or just click the link in the video description.
Have fun with the video!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!